the wasteland is harsh and unforgiving
today we're showing you the best
techniques for combat in the game and
how the squad you create and build will
determine your success bringing justice
to the Arizona wastes begins with
character creation you can choose
pre-made squad members or create your
own customized elite team of desert
Rangers attributes skills weapons
specializations appearance right down to
your Rangers choice of cigarettes
we're gonna build a heavy weapon
specialist with a talent for modding his
guns coordination is one of the main
attributes controlling our ability to
use guns bonus range to hit chance means
we'll stay on target more action points
means we'll get to move and fire more
each turn a few points into awareness
helps ranged characters the bonus
initiative helps us act sooner in combat
extra evasion helps us avoid incoming
fire and the mainly critical chance
increase is good if our enemies get too
close for comfort our heavy weapons guy
is in a complete meathead we're giving
him a point in intelligence so he gets
more skill points at each level up
finally this guy's an [ __ ] let's dump
two points out of charisma and put them
into strength now you can carry more
gear they call them heavy weapons for a
reason let's move on to skills heavy
weapons ensures that our man is good
with a wide variety of machine guns
grenades rocket launchers and more
weapon smithing lets him strip down guns
he doesn't need for parts and use those
parts to add much to the guns he wants
to keep and use finally it's good to
have a fallback skill in case someone
gets too close for comfort the point in
brawling will work well together with
his upgraded strength and awareness now
for some personality his name is chutes
Jorgensen he's a nihilistic drunk from
the nuclear wastes around my know North
Dakota
the game offers you dozens of options
for character heads hair hats skin tones
clothing and more you can create a sharp
professional looking squad of Rangers or
a motley crew more concerned with
results than appearances or something
completely unique now we build three
more Rangers were picked from the pre
generated characters to fill out our
squad make sure you cover all the bases
because building a balanced squad is key
to battlefield success don't forget a
field medic and a surgeon
our squad arrives in the town of Demonte
far to the east of Ranger Citadel we're
looking to Commission a radio tower to
help broadcast our message of hope and
security across the waves as we get into
town something doesn't feel right our
Rangers aren't prepared for what they're
about to face this might not go well
yes we're gonna need some more recruits
let's take a look and see how the right
squad could have survived its onslaught
this time we've outfitted our squad with
the right tools for the job
we've got specialist in anti-armor
energy weapons heavy weapons and blunt
weapons all of which we'll punch through
those robots thick metal shells our
sniper is trained as a surgeon and will
be able to revive anyone down for the
count let's kick things off with a bang
our heavy weapons specialist advances
and takes his shot that lures the robots
in he then retreats to let the rest of
the team tear them apart
notice how we stay crouched to gain a
bonus to hit you can see how the right
guns skills and Rangers turn this fight
from a suicide mission into a manageable
tactical situation but you can bet
there's some other situations somewhere
else in the wasteland where this
rough-and-tumble squad built for mass
destruction will find their damage
dealing skills ill-equipped for the task
at hand here we are in Happy Valley
better known is the prison
the Rangers old home base and now home
to the competing Red Scorpion militia
here we'll take advantage of higher
terrain to gain better accuracy going
for the headshot is a gamble that will
reduce your chance to hit the pays off
with increased damage even if you've got
to rein on your side you might need to
take cover but cover is a resource to
your targets we'll get into cover two
and much of it can be destroyed
mastering the battlefield will help you
master your enemies you don't have to
just rely on your Rangers you can
recruit a wide variety of denizens of
the wastes from other Rangers who will
join you for a period of time to doctors
hobos and even a robot here we've
reprogrammed Jamie the robot to help us
liberate Demont a--from invasion
here's Jamie dealing some damage here is
Jamie taking some damage and here's
Jamie doing something special that's not
just pretty lights that area of effect
gives enemies an accuracy penalty when
nearby let's use our skills to give them
a hand
now we're ready to go you made your
choices you trained your squad but no
amount of training in Arizona will
prepare you for the challenges of
California that you'll experience during
the game's second half